Today, we are talking about growing your
email list because if you do not have an
email list, you will struggle to make
money online. And if you want to grow
your list fast, you need to create
context congruency, which I'm going to
show you how to do so simply that a
10-year-old could get it. By the way,
I'm Allan Drago. I've grown my email
list to over 5,000 loyal subscribers,
and I've made over $77,000
from my email list in just the last few
months alone. This is what I do all day
long. So, when it comes to growing your
email list, there are really only two
metrics that you need to understand, and
that is traffic and conversion rate. And
we're going to dive into conversion rate
before we dive into traffic, and I'm
going to show you why. I'm going to show
you what this looks like in practical
examples. So, traffic is 100 people land
on the opt-in page to your email list.
Conversion rate is how many of those
people actually give you their email to
join your list. So, traffic is total
number, conversion rate is number of
people who give you their email. So, for
example, if 100 people land on your
website landing page to join your email
list or see your pop-up or something
like that, and 10 of them actually give
you their email address, that is a 10%
conversion rate, okay? So, the only way
to grow your list is to increase the
number of people who land on that page
or increase the percentage of the
conversion rate. And I'm going to tell
you right now, it is much easier to
increase your conversion rate than it is
to increase your traffic. But let me
show you a couple example. If you
increase the traffic to your email
opt-in, let's say you get 200 people to
land on your email opt-in, and 10% of
them, it's still the same 10% join, then
you get 20 new email addresses instead
of 10. That's increasing the traffic.
But if you get 100 people, the same 100
people we originally talked about, and
20%
join, then you get 20 people. Do you see
how we could flip-flop the two? You have
to understand this concept before I
break down exactly what you need to do
next with a method I call the illegal
bribe to get them to join your list.
But, I'm going to say it again, it is
easier to increase conversion rate than
it is traffic because you already have
the traffic coming to your site. It's
way harder to get fresh eyeballs and new
people to your landing page to join your
email list than it is to get the
existing people to become persuaded to
give you their email address. And now
I'm going to show you how you can do
that. The idea behind people jumping
into your email list has to do with this
concept I call context congruency. You
have to think about it like this, okay?
You have someone who is in the context
before they got to your email page.
Think about this. Your people didn't
just land on the page willy-nilly. They
came from somewhere. That context could
be from Meta Ads, which is cold traffic,
or maybe a social media post, or maybe
you sent direct mail to their house with
an opt-in to your list. There's all
kinds of ways for people to end up
landing on your email page, and that
context matters because the context is
what's going to create the leap, okay?
The context is the environment that they
were just in. How closely related does
it match the email opt-in that you're
asking for their information? For
example, here's an article that I wrote.
So, the context in this case would be
the article. I wrote an article on five
free ways to grow your email list to
1,000. That is the context. So, think
about this. People are reading this
article on Twitter, on Substack,
anything like that. That is the context
of the world that they are in. How am I
going to move them from that context to
actually giving me their email address
and joining my email list? Well, the
thing that I do in this article is at
the very end of the article, I offer
them a bribe. And I'm going to break
this down here shortly. But I offer them
a bribe where I say, "If you enjoyed
this article, then you would love the
one email that I used to grow my list by
over a thousand people almost overnight.
Click this to steal that email." What
that is, it's congruency with the
context, aka context congruency. They
read an article about growing their
email list and in exchange for me to get
their email, I'm offering them an
illegal bribe, which I'll break down
more in a second, that directly matches
the context they were in. It's also a
bribe to help them grow their email
list. Read an email about how to grow
their email list and then get them to
opt into my email list so I can help
them continue to grow their email list.
How meta is this, by the way? This is
insane that I did that. Let me show you
one more example, okay? Here's another
video that I did called the secret AI
hack for rapid market research. So, the
context is that I posted an organic
video on YouTube about market research,
specifically how to use AI to do market
research. And then while you're watching
that video, in the description down
below, I give you a link to actually
grab the AI prompts that I'm using in
the video. To grab those prompts, you
give me the email address, which means
you join my email and I send you the
prompts. So, the context congruency
makes it a very small leap. Meaning,
they're watching a video about market
research, watching me use the AI
prompts, and then I say, "Hey, if you
want these prompts, put your email
address down below." So, the leap is
very small. That's the big idea is you
have to make the leap from what they're
doing contextually to why they need to
give you their email address. A weaker
example of content congruency would be
like if I wrote that article about how
to grow your email list, but then my
bribe for you to join my list was my
copywriting crash course, I could say,
"Hey, growing your email list is really
helpful if you write good copy, so grab
this." But, do you see how the leap is
bigger, right? If I go back to this,
what I'm asking someone to do is take a
bigger leap. Their context is growing
their email list, and then I'm saying,
"Oh, also copy writing
is helpful." So, now I'm asking you to
jump further contextually. Get out of
the whole growing your list world and
get into the world of copywriting. I'm
asking them to jump their mindset, which
creates a lower conversion rate. But,
the smaller the leap over here, the
higher the conversion rate. So, you need
to shrink the leap. Now, once the leap
is small, we make it sexy. This is where
I start introducing my concept called
the illegal bribe. It's a bribe to join
your email list that's so good that it
almost feels illegal that you're giving
it away to them for free. There are two
ways to make a bribe feel illegal. The
first way is it's something that people
pay for. A great example of this is Ben
Settle. Ben Settle is one of the most
world-renowned email copywriters. And
when you go to bensettle.com, he has two
things that he prompts you before you
join his email list that almost feels
illegal. You get a copy of his $97 per
month Email Players Newsletter, which is
a newsletter that I've paid for for
almost 4 years. $97 a month, that is
thousands of dollars, and he's going to
give you one for free for joining his
email list, which is something that
other people have to pay for. The next
thing is that he's going to give you
access to his app that's over 40 hours
of copywriting training. That is
something that other people pay
thousands of dollars for to learn
copywriting from other creators. These
two things alone to join his email list,
how could you not want to slap your
email address in there and be like, yes,
give me those things and immediately
jump on his list. That is an illegal
bribe. The next thing is an illegal
bribe is something that you cannot get
anywhere else. A great example of this
is my friend Daniel Throssell. So,
Daniel Throssell did this thing back in
2020 called the parallel welcome
sequence. It's this crazy bombastic
welcome sequence where he does this
storytelling thing where he tosses you
in a world where you're getting chased
by monsters and you've been kidnapped
and you just have to keep clicking
through the stories and it takes you
back and forth between your email and
your browser and it's this wild
experience that I've never seen happen
anywhere else and he got a bunch of
raving testimonials just about his
welcome experience. Well, what do you do
to get somebody's welcome emails? Well,
you put your email list in and that is
an experience that you will not get
anywhere else, which creates this
increased desire where it's like, man,
that feels like illegal that all I have
to do is put my email address in and I
get to go through this experience that
is so cool, that is so raved about by
other people and I just get to enjoy it
for free. So, those are two ways for you
to be able to create this desire to
increase your conversion rate to join
your email. But, you have to remember
that the leap needs to be small. Like,
for example, if we go back to Ben
Settle's, well, what is he offering you?
He's offering you his email player
subscription to understand email
copywriting and he's offering you 40
hours plus of copywriting training. The
context of where he he his leads and
gets his traffic should be a copywriting
context because if they're learning and
understanding about Ben from the
copywriting perspective and then his
illegal bribes or about copywriting, the
leap is small. But if they hear Ben on a
podcast talking about his options
trading business and then they land on
his website and he's offering
copywriting tools, well, that leap is
significantly bigger. Less people will
join his list based on the context that
they came from, context congruency. But
that leads us to the next question is,
how do we increase traffic? Okay, if we
can increase our conversion rate, let's
win both sides of growing this list.
Well, yes, there are two ways that you
can increase traffic to your email
opt-in list so that your conversion rate
can rip and get more subscribers faster.
The first one is to run ads to your
bribe. Okay, that illegal bribe Alex
Hormozi does this wonderfully. So, this
is a screenshot of an ad that Alex
Hormozi has run in some form or fashion
for the last 2 and 1/2 years. So, I know
he's personally put millions of dollars
behind this ad. So, I know it works,
okay? And what he does is says,
"Business owners, real quick, can I get
your email address? I want to send you
the exact frameworks that I've used to
scale sales, teams, communication, all
that stuff." It's his scaling
frameworks. And if you watch the video
I've It's kind of cut off there, but if
you've watched the video, you click the
link down here where it says the five
scaling frameworks and you put your
email address in. Now, the context of
this is that he's got to use really good
targeting to get in front of the right
people who are interested in scaling
their business. If they are not
interested in scaling their business,
then you have a very large context
congruency leap. But if you get in front
of the right people and you run ads, you
pay money to get in front of those
people, then the leap is tiny and
they're going to put their email address
and you can blow up your list fast, but
that could cost a lot of money and a lot
of people don't want to spend money on
ads to grow their email list. They want
to do it the free way. So, the second
way is repurposing winning content. Let
me show you what that looks like. So, if
you remember my market research video
that I did to collect a bunch of emails.
Well, that actually came from a YouTube
short that I created. I did a YouTube
short, I don't know, like 2 years ago
and it was three dead simple tips to do
market research as a copywriter. Well,
that video got over 2,000 views almost
in 1 day and I said, "Whoa, that's
that's a lot more than I usually get."
It was usually at the time 2 to 300
views on a short, but this one got 10
times the amount of views. So, that So,
I took that and I said, "Well, people
are really interested in this topic. It
was a winner." So, I took that and I
turned it into a long-form video, which
did 4.4 times as many views. It's at
10,000 views right now than the rest of
my content. And then what I did was I
turned that into an illegal bribe where
I said, "Hey, here's how you can hack
your best customers' brains in just 15
minutes with these market research AI
prompts." And it's an opt-in page that
looks exactly like this where they put
in their email address. I persuade them
to give me their email address in
exchange for the prompts. All of that
came from just understanding the content
that was resonating with my audience.
So, it started with a 60-second short. I
turned that into a 10-minute video and
then I turned that into an illegal bribe
that got people to give me their email
address. In fact, I've collected over
2,000 email addresses from that one
video alone. That's how powerful context
congruency can be. Now, I do want to
give you a bonus tip on how to grow your
list and that is the email that I
referenced earlier. It is the one email
that got me over a thousand new
subscribers almost overnight. In fact,
when you put your email address here,
I'm going to send you the email and a 10
to 15 minute training on what it is I
did to break it down, make that email so
fun, so persuasive that by word of mouth
it got out to everybody including email
celebrities in my industry that we're
talking about it. So, go ahead and click
the link down below to grab that. After
you do that, something else that may be
really helpful for you, stick around.
There's going to be a video popping up
on the screen. It is my two hour
copywriting masterclass. Copywriting is
by far one of the most persuasive and
valuable skills on the planet to help
you write better emails to grow your
list, entertain your people, and sell
more stuff. If you have not watched
that, I highly encourage you to stick
around, click that video, enjoy all of
the tactics from that copywriting
masterclass so you can write better
emails and sell more stuff. Thank you so
much for taking the time to watch this
video. I hope you found it really
helpful. I hope you really enjoyed it.
Like and subscribe to the channel to
tell me that you want me to make more
content like this, and I will catch you
on the next one.
>> [music]
[music]